hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
Appy couple how smartphone apps are
helping parents get through pregnancy
available for one day only Google glass
goes on sale but do people really want
it drop it like it's hot rapper Snoop
Dogg moves into gaming and it's all
kicking off in this week's games review
with our sports special having a baby
has to be one of the most stressful
things a couple can go through but take
a look at the apt choice and you'd be
forgiven for thinking the solution to a
stress-free pregnancy could be in your
pocket some of the biggest selling
smartphone downloads have been designed
to help expectant parents skies Katie
Spencer has been exploring the boom in
baby making apps with baby isabelle just
three weeks old there aren't many
opportunities for mum Lauren to sit down
and enjoy a bit of quiet time it's a
whole new experiences a whole new thing
that you've never done before and no one
can really prepare you for when your
baby arrives so like an increasing
number of expectant parents blogger
Lauren sought out a little help online
Isabelle's journey into the world was
supported by a number of smartphone and
iPad apps he said how irregular
contractions and I picked up my phone
she went oh you've got a nap it was good
to be able to show the Midwife this is
how regular my contractions are there
like right we need to get used to the
year the delivery room then in the last
few years there's been a boom in baby
apps designed to give advice and support
to expectant mums and dads with the
maternity market worth billions it's
become a lucrative area that developers
a keen to tap into apps like pregnancy
plus help the user track their pregnancy
in greater detail with a kick counter
and contraction timer little is left to
chance what Meister aimed at women
there's now even a concerted effort to
cater for the men with apps like who's
your daddy we wrote the app in a
humorous way that would just this is not
to replace doctors or mid wives or
partners and make a lot of the advice in
the app is talk to people with hi babies
tracking apps can even be used with
fetal monitors to listen to the baby's
heartbeat in the home today's technology
can enable you to access new information
that you couldn't access before without
going to let's say to care providers
office the download figures may speak
for themselves but critics argue that
some smart phone apps can want to be a
little too involved you can record
absolutely everything about your baby if
you want see so when they're feeding
sleeping pooing and taking pictures of
everything all the different memories
and it's possible to go completely over
bars I think while having an app that
can keep track of the more special
moments during a pregnancy as clearly
part of the appeal taking the time to
enjoy the experience of becoming a new
mom or dad can sometimes mean putting
the smartphone away Katy Spencer Sky
News you're watching swype coming up
he's one of america's most wanted men
but Kim calm wants to move into politics
but first google glass has been around
for a while but we couldn't go out and
buy a pair until now this week the tech
giant held a special one-day sale in the
states where stocks quickly ran out but
can google really justify the 900-pound
price tag skies Greg Milam went to meet
glass user Bethany Simpson to find out
okay it's a game-changing device but
it's not a groundbreaking device and so
I don't know the people who have it have
it you know if there are people who are
real technologists who want to get in
and get hands on with it you know
they've been saving up their pennies and
they actually want to spend the pool
$1,500 I mean today's the day you know I
hope you've done it but it's there's not
nearly as much chatter as I thought but
they're still weird to where the public
has not accepted them obviously we've
heard all of the stories come out of San
Francisco you know where there's
snatched off of faces and things like
that it's just a bizarre device I mean I
have my hair covering most of the
battery pack so this is as unobtrusive
as any user will ever have it and I'm a
friendly looking blonde female so I have
very positive interactions about glass
but it I never wear it in public because
people don't know quite what to do with
it it's so much fun to see what people
are doing with it I love seeing in
medical you know across you know police
and emergency
it's great for travel is great for
tourism it's fascinating it's just not
sticky yet it's a great device I love it
I utterly geek out on it it's in no way
worth fifteen hundred dollars unless
you're making a specific investment but
then again like you were to ask me is it
worth should somebody go out and buy it
today if you are truly a geek from the
inside who just wants to be hands-on
with something that is brand new that
nobody's that are really touched before
one of the first ten to fifteen thousand
sure you know if you've been saving your
pennies and you just want to get in yes
it is geeky fun it is fascinating there
more updates and more apps coming every
day for those guys yeah it's right you
know I that's why I wanted to get in i I
just I couldn't not be a first google
user but if you're a consumer if you're
at all on the fence it's not worth it at
all and I say wait and hope that they
bring the price point down by at least a
thousand dollars and then you can play
with the idea then you're watching swype
coming up why gamers could be getting a
pep talk from one of the biggest names
in rap always out the joint is 42 but
first Kim calm may be fighting
extradition to the US but that isn't
stopping him from getting on his soapbox
the megaupload founder has decided to
create a political party dedicated to
promoting Internet freedom and what
better way to kick things off than by
inviting a few hundred people over to
your new zealand mansion skies Chloe
Colburn reports he's one of the most
wanted people in the US Kim comms
accused of copyright infringement on a
huge scale relating to the now-closed
mega upload file sharing site but
despite the threat of extradition he
remains defiant this is a war about a
technology and innovations that they
don't like and I'm being made an example
the german-born millionaires been on
bail for two years but it hasn't curbed
his ambitions he's created a new file
storage company called mega and has now
formed the internet party to promote
online freedom and privacy reform he
might be persona non grata abroad but in
New Zealand he's found plenty of support
it's not the mr dot com personality
what's important it's the ideas
on top of the 2012 charges com also
faces lawsuits from music labels and
Hollywood studios so he knows staying
out of jail won't be easy the biggest
problem i'm going to have in the u.s. is
that almost ninety percent of the media
is controlled by the same parties that
are suing me that want to destroy me so
they are going to make sure that their
mesh message is the one being heard and
online and you know i think they're
going to manipulate the media in order
to make sure that i will be portrayed as
of the lin and as a criminal if he loses
the case calm think the implications
could be huge with other companies
potentially facing prosecution if i lose
they all lose and they all know that you
know because this is a much bigger play
than just me i mean after they are done
with me in their dream world they're
going to go after google and youtube and
drop box and all these other sites and
will force them to change their models
his critics call it a vanity project but
Kim calm describes the internet party as
New Zealand's newest most awesome
political movement but if he's
extradited it could be a long time
before he's around to enjoy the party
Khloe kolpin Sky News you're watching
swype coming up around the Gulf with
Mario but first here's a roundup of
anything you might have missed over the
last few days the head of one of
Europe's biggest newspaper publishers
has hit out at Google's dominance in an
open letter media tycoon Axel Springer
has written that many of his colleagues
are too afraid to speak about how
powerful the search engine has become he
also asked Google boss Eric Schmidt if
he's trying to create a digital super
state that operates in a legal vacuum
Google is yet to respond meanwhile
google has bought the US drone company
Titan aerospace the tech firm wants to
use the solar-powered rose to spread
internet access across the developing
world
the collapse Japanese Bitcoin exchange
mount Cox has gone into administration
earlier this year it lost 850,000
bitcoins worth about half a billion
dollars after an alleged theft by
hackers since then 200,000 bitcoins have
been recovered but authorities are still
trying to find out what happened candy
crush is going to China the mobile games
being launched by chinese tech giant
tencent holdings to a potential audience
of 225 million users sales have dropped
off in the US and Europe so this could
give the business a huge boost shares in
the games makers King fell by as much as
sixteen percent last month when the
company went public stress our call of
duty fans now have the chance to get pep
talks from one of the most laid-back
rappers in the music business rack up
points by reaching the enemy portal you
did Snoop Dogg has lent his voice to the
call of duty game franchise for as
ghosts multiplayer voice back so if you
want advice on which weapons to usual
tips on strategy snoops your man I think
the writers did a good job on creating
the lives for me specifically for me
they knew my flavor and they allowed me
to you know do my thing put a little
Snoopy as am on top of this summer is
going to be a big one for sports fans
England head to the world cup in brazil
the Tour de France rolls into Yorkshire
and the Ryder Cup has to Scotland so we
thought we'd get in the mood by asking
gaming expert guy Cocker to take a look
at a few new sport releases so it's a
World Cup year so that means there's
going to be a new FIFA themed world cup
game the big thing about this particular
one is that it's being released on xbox
360 and playstation 3 which is kind of
weird because we've now moved on to the
next generation of consoles and it's
essentially based on last year's fifa
game so it plays really really work
plays I'm really really game football
and I can't help but admit to talk being
swept up in it as I'm playing it because
you can you can play as England in my
case and take mine through to the world
cup finals and when the World Cup files
are actually happening in a couple of
months time there's an interesting new
feature web whereby whatever scenario
your wheel team gets into into a real in
real life an hour after that game you'll
be able to replay through that's enough
so if england win to nil you can reply
that scenario and and or if they lose
heaven forbid you can try and fix it in
the game by winning so it's kind of a
cool as kind of a cool mechanic if i
have a problem with it it's that the
euro 2012 game a couple years ago was
released as a downloadable add-on to
that year's fifa game whereas this is a
full price release it's coming out
pretty much less well just over six
months after last game it feels feel
like it's kind of a you know it's an
expensive game just for the World Cup
experience but I did i do admit i got
swept up in it i'm really looking
forward to the work at five football
manager a 2014 is a really really
in-depth football simulator it's
basically the idea behind it is you
manage your team there is a 3d match
engine but it's not like fifa you you're
the manager so you're performing all the
back room stuff your training players
you're recruiting new players to your to
your squad and i think about it is if
you talk to football manager players
there sometimes like they're like
addicts that they get addicted to this
game so because just because it's so in
depth this is the first time that it's
come to Vita the game itself on vita
works really well its got touchscreen
controls which i think is really really
nice it's the best version of this game
that bet the best portable version of
the game at least it's not for everyone
it's because it does look like an Excel
spreadsheet when you look at it but if
you're a football fan there's no other
foot will manage a game that really
offers this level of depth and I really
got back into the game and played it on
PC through having it on the go so if
you're if you're an addict or a past
addict like me then then watch out but
it's a very very good game
if you were a fan of Nintendo sports
games it can feel like they're really so
many of them as mario tennis Mario
golfers Liz so many of them on so many
different platforms but there's actually
not been a mario golf on a handheld
since the game boy advance which was
quite a long time ago so mario golf is
actually quite a deep and rewarding golf
game if you want it to be you can set a
difficulty quite high have a complex
input and obviously choose your choose
your golf clubs and also but it's got
that mario spin on it so you collect
coins in the air you can get mario
power-ups as power up blocks the big
thing about this game is because on 3d s
you can put in the world tour as it
suggests you can play online so you can
play online with your friends it's not
doing anything that we haven't seen
before but it's a more accessible golf
game if the likes of Tiger Woods a bit
scary trials has been a really big
success story for a small indie
developer they've been a couple of games
in this series started out as a flash
game online very basic flash game made
it on xbox 360 and now it's a
multi-platform title and this one is on
next gen consoles I've been playing it
on the PlayStation 4 you have a side-on
view when you control a motorbike rider
and he's on he's on a bike and that the
kind of the gameplay loop that the
really addictive thing about it is the
physics are very very realistic so
you're trying to balance this bike up
hills and perform all these stunts and
it's just very very addictive and it
gets very very hard the tracks are
really really fiendish now the big thing
for this version of the game like I said
they're been to previous versions is
this futuristic setting it looks
absolutely gorgeous on next-gen consoles
the only problem i have it i love the
trials games i absolutely love them is
that maybe as a fan i'd expect something
a bit more at this stage has been a
couple of games previously and it's a
cliche to say it you know if you like
trials you will get something out of it
but it's maybe starting to feel like
they're milking the formula or a little
bit
that's it for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking tech stories
all week on Sky News for iPad smartphone
apps and Sky News calm and see you next
time bye bye